abone ol
bu
[Müzik]
Merhabalar Öncelikle
inanılmaz bir kalabalık var Denizli'ye
gösterdiği Özen için çok teşekkür
ediyorum galiba ya Daha önce de
kalabalığa konuştum ama kalıp
konuşturmayın kalabalık kitlelerden bir
tanesi çok teşekkür ediyorum
şimdi bir iki bir şey söylemek istedim
Öncelikle bir konuşmalar arasında bir
küre dönüyor ya bizim bu mavi küre miz
uzaydan bilye gibi gözüken nefis
Dünyamız bugün göstereceğim şey ona
sevgim ve saygımdandır biraz karamsar
başlayabilirim ama
de iyiyim saniyeden sağlamak için
karamsar başlayacağım yani Hani ilk kötü
haberleri vereceğim sonra iyi haberleri
vereceğim diyelim Umarım
bir de bir büyüme veya bir başarı
hikâyesinden daha çok bir küçülme
hikayesi Anlatmaya çalışacağım sanırım
bundan sonraki
sırayla daha şu an kesildi galiba geldi
gene
slime'lar da onu anlatabileceğim olmuyor
şimdi
Ömür biter yol bitmez kamyoncuların
çilesi bitmez anlamına gelir genellikle
Ama ben daha çok çareler seçenekler
tükenmez her zaman Bir çıkar yol vardır
anlamında kullanıyorum kelimeyi bir de
şu ana kadar gittiğim yol gidilebilecek
Yollar veya belki de gidilmeyecek yollar
üzerine bir şey yapmayı umuyorum
eğitiminden Bak şimdi ki de Şehir ve
Bölge Planlama eğitimi aldım şu yani
büyük ölçekte başladım
Şu Ama gördüm ki şehirleri siyaset ve
Ser bu şekillendiriyoruz plancılar değil
bu mesela Kanal İstanbul güzergahı
üzerinde bir emlak
ofisi ve işte üçüncü köprü Kanal
İstanbul 3 havalimanı gibi Mega
projeleri
bir şekilde promosyon malzemesi olarak
kullanılan bir ilan-ı asmış arsalarımız
nakit alınır satılır falan Bu da
İstanbul'un ipini çekecek projenin
güzergahına yakın bir yerlerden çekilmiş
Kanal İstanbul
Projesi'nin güzergahının geçeceği yer
yani çok kötü çevre birincisi diyor ki
Kanal İstanbul yapılırsa bütün Karadeniz
ve
Marmara denizi arasındaki fon sistemi
bozulacak ve ve Marmara denizi çürük
yumurta gibi kokmaya başlayacak
daha sonra emaneti Yani nasıl Street
Boston Amerika da bir okul önemli bir
mühendislik Okulu orada Mimarlık yüksek
bu
çalışması yaptım Bu da venedikte bir
pira arsenal'e diye anılan bir bölgede
diğerlerinin yapıldığı bölge Bir
denizcilik Müzesi projesi
asid onu kesit kesit ipi Mimarlık
çalışmaları daha sonra University of
California Kaliforniya Üniversitesi
berkeley kampüsünde sütlü tasarımı ve
mobilya tasarımı Üzerine Bazı çalışmalar
yaptım Bu bir yaya Köprüsü tasarımı Bu
da bir başucu o masası tasarımı bunun
tasarımı da ben yaptım İnş aslında ben
kendi başıma yaptım
oh oh
mimarlık'ın temelde Medeni standartlarda
barınma ihtiyacını hizmet ettiğini Mut
ettim mezuniyet sonrasında Bu mesleğin
siyasi ve Finansal erkeğin en büyük
aygıtlarından birisi olduğunu keşfettim
ki Mimarlık bir küçük ölçekte şehir
plancılığı na göre bu İstanbul'dan Bazı
fotoğraflar neredeyse distopik
kelimesi kullanılabilir Bu fotoğraflar
için
ve bunların bazıları sanat eseri
bazıları da
belgesel fotoğraf
Ama bu bir sanat eseri İstanbul
modern'in koleksiyon da yer alıyor Bu
arada
de bir AVM
Yok be abi İstanbul çeperlerinde yer
alan periferide yanan bir Lüks konut
projesi
Amerika'daki gittim sonrasında bir
seneliğine sosyalist bir Amerikalı
mimarın yanındaki Amerika'da Sosyalist
insan bulmak çok zordur çok güzel denk
geldi bana staj yaptım tasarım hizmetine
Bedeli ödeyemeyecek ihtiyaç sahiplerine
gaz lıkları küçük projeler ürettik çok
heyecan verici bir tecrübe değer
Türkiye'ye döndükten sonra böyle bir
ofis bulsaydım hala Mimarlık yapıyor
olurdum diye düşünüyorum bu mesela Özgün
adıyla tohan Oo tam Türkçe'ye çevrilmesi
ile de çöl halkı adında bir kabile
yaptığımız bir yaşlılar Merkezi
projesiyle tamamla taştan
ve inşa edildi ben ne yazık inşa etmiş
Hani göremedim bu onun paketidir benim
maket yapmaya çok seviyorum Ben elimi
becerilerini kullanmayı
Bu da
Mimarlık ofisinin sahibi
de böyle gibis
onun
ona onu ofise gitmeden önce emaneti de
ben Mimarlık okurken bir inşaat atölyesi
çalışmasına liderlik etmiştir bende hep
böyle devamlı çiziyoruz ediyoruz falan
fakat yani malzemeyi tanımıyoruz bir şey
inşa etmiyorsan çok katılmak istedim
zaten öyle Çünkü Tamam ile ellerimizi
betona harca taşa toprağa bulayarak
Tamam ve kendi ellerimizle bir şeyler
inşa ettik ve Gayette sağlam şey inşa
ettik
endüstri devrimi sonrasında
hegemonyasını ilan eden Batı merkezli
küresel kapitalizmin den merkezciliği
çifte standartları ayrımcılıkları
acımasız rekabeti en zenginler leğen
yoksullar arasındaki farkı giderek
artmasına yol açtı bu günümüzde bize
dayatılan hız ve rekabet yüzünden
paylaşmayı yardımlaşmayı yetinmeyi
tevazuyu nezaketi zerafeti sadeliği
tasarrufu ve emanetleri Ben bunu yerine
israfı ifratı gösterişi vermeden almayı
rüküş bir zevksiz liği koy rahatlığı
zulmü rüyayı Beyhan etleri benimsemiş
görünüyoruz
Güya birayı odaklı bir hayat yaşanıyor
ama kişisel verileri toplayan ve iş
dünyasına satan şirketler dünyanın
küresel ölçekte en değerli markaları
haline geldi dünyanın en bilinen Ekonomi
Dergisi belki ya da dergilerinden bir
tanesinde economist
burada kapakta Gördüğünüz üzere verinin
dünyanın önemli en önemli kaynağı haline
geldiğini söylüyor yani konuştuğunu
söylüyorsa böyledir dünyayı yönetenlerin
dergisi Çünkü
Kent ise artık Esaret yeri aldığımız tüm
hizmetlerde bağımlıyız akıllı şehirler
akıl ve becerilerini yitiren insanlar
oluşmasına yol açabiliyor burada bir
videodan durağın ekran görüntüleri aldım
Bu bir mizansen video gerçek Bu bir
fakat Geleceğe dair bir projeksiyon
altında da eğer bir enerji kesintisi
yüzünden bir yürüyen merdiven birden
duruyor ve onun üzerindeki insanlar
çok çaresiz bir şekilde buna çok
üzülüyorlar yardım çağrısı yapıyorlar
sana yürümek akıllarına gelmiyor Çünkü
artık yürümeyi unutmaya yakınlar Çünkü
akıllı sistemler onlar için her türlü
hizmeti onlara veriyor Bu da bol iyi
adlı bir animasyon filminden alınmış bir
kaç tane ekran görüntüsü Burada da aynı
şey var
oradan oraya orada Buradan oraya gitmek
için bir makinaya bağımlı halde kalmış
insanlar ve bu yüzden de kilo almış
artık yürüyemeyecek hale gelen insanlar
genelde enerji kesin kesintisi olduğunda
yürümeyi dediklerinde yürü yemedikleri
görüyorlar ve yuvarlanmaya başlıyorlar
Yani bunlar tabii bazı şu an mevcut olan
durumlar değil Fakat İngilizce güzel bir
laf vardır yuze Thor lusit diye Ya niye
yakılan ya da yani tamam ya hani
Kaybolsun elinden gitsin bu hayal
kırıklıkları sonucunda ölçeği küçültmeye
olabildiğince bağımsız olmayan ve en
sevdiğim hobim olan fotoğrafı hayatının
merkezine koymaya karar verdim
şimdilerde sanatçı Sabancı
Üniversitesi'nde akademisyen ve
profesyonel olarak
Fotoğrafçılık yaparak hayatıma devam
ediyorum yani fotoğrafı hayatının tam
merkezine koydum yaptığım her şey
fotoğrafta şu veya bu şekilde bağlantılı
bu İstanbul Modern yani galerileri ve
müzeler ile işbirliği yapıyorum çeşit
sergileri için çok büyük heyecan vs
benim için İstanbul modern'de yaptığım
bir kişisel sergi 2010 yılında ve
enteresandır serginin başlığı yol burada
İşte gördüğünüz yol üzerine çeşidi
sattığı mallar var Bu da aynı sadece
içerisinde 14 metrelik bir Panorama ile
ifade ettim şark Ekspresi üzerine bir
ilişki doğudan
Ya dur giden bir
pren bu bu serginin kavram ettiğinden
bir şeyler okumak istedim Çünkü konuyla
alakalı olduğunu düşünüyorum yol bize
bulmayı öğretir ya da bulduğumuzu
sandığımızdan kurtula bilmeyi hayatı
değiştirebilecek rastlantılar Yoldayken
karşımıza çıkar yol yürürken şekillenir
diğer değiştir Kervan yolda düzülür
yolunu gözlediğimiz çıkar yolu
keşfetmenin yollarından biri yola
çıkmaktır burada farkındaysanız farklı
Yolları farklı renklerle
işaretleri Çünkü yol kelimesinin farklı
anlamları gelebiliyor farklı bağlamlarda
kullandığınızı yol iki taraf arasındaki
araftır devamlı yoldaolmak diri tarafsız
ve uyanık tutar
bu bu bu da bir galerideki yaptım Bir
iki saat sergiden bir kare bu sergide de
kitlesel insan
hareketlerinde hem katılımcı hem de
belgesel fotoğrafçı olarak
katıldığı mi Orada çektiğim
fotoğrafların adım adım yukarıya doğru
yükselen bir merdivene giydirilmesi nden
oluşan bir Saki ya fotoğrafın üç boyuta
çıkması diyebiliriz Bu da
seferde artık telefoncuya bir galeride
2010'da açtığım Pardon kim 20'de 20'de
açtım bir sergi burada Mimar Kerem piker
li işbirliği yaptık ortada gördüğünüz
fotografik yerleştirmeyi kendisi
tasarladığı benim etrafta tanımından
sonra
burada komidin yol açtığı bir fiziksel
mesafe meselesi vardı yani İlk başlarda
biliyorsunuz ki sosyal mesafe derler ben
çok tehlikeli buluyorum sosyal mesafe
lafını fiziksel olarak bir o ayrı durmak
zorunda kalabiliriz Evet ama bu sosyal
olarak birimizden ayrılmamız gerektiği
anlamına gelmiyor Ve bunu eleştiren bir
sergi metni vardı ve ortada gördüğünüz
1100 adet ve fotoğraf var ve bunlar
dünyanın farklı Kent kentlerinde farklı
kültürlerin de çekilmiş farklı
insan fotoğrafları ve bunların bir araya
getirilmesiyle Bir küresel beraberlik
manzaraları oluşturmakta niyetim
Evet
bu da Antalya Kültür Sanat aldığı müzede
açılmış bir kişisel sergi bu serginin
tasarımda da yeşildemir bir grafik
tasarımcı ve sergi tasarımları da
yapıyor Onunla işbirliği yaptık
işbirliklerini çok seviyorum çünkü benim
kendi başına ortaya çıkarmayacağım Bazı
şeylerin ortaya çıkmasını sağlıyor bu
işbirlikleri beni geliştiriyor işbirliği
tek başıma da hoşuma giden şeyler
yapıyorum ama işbirliğinin esprili bana
çok daha fazla şey kata biliyor bu da
Antalya'da bazı emanetler
belirledim Antalya larla konuşarak
Antalya için önemli şeyler ve onları ne
türlü ihanetler gerçekleştiriyoruz
onları anlamaya çalıştım de bu genel
olarak tabi bir saniye Doğa bir emanet
olarak ve biz aşırı kentleşme ve onun
getirdiği içi şeylerle doğaya nasıl
ihanet ediyoruz
onu konu edinen bir şey ve sergi bir de
şunu söylemek istiyorum O biraz kibirli
bir canlıyız Ya insan ırkı ve Diyoruz ki
duayı yok edeceğiz bundan vazgeçmemiz
lazım bizim doğayı yok etmek gibi bir
gücümüz yok Biz olsa olsa kendimizi yok
edeceğiz Doğa Tabii ki her zamanki gibi
geri dönecek ve belki Hani dönüşüm
muhteşem olacak Yani biz doğal yok
edemeyiz bunu
bir kafamıza kazanmamız lazım Biz ancak
olsa olsa bir şey yok edecekse kendinizi
yok edebilir ve o yolda bayağı hızla
ilerliyoruz
belgesel ağırlıklı çalışıyorum
emanetlerimize karşı işlediği suçlara
ortak olmamak ve olay yeri inceleme
uzmanı gibi işlenen çeşitli suçların
delillerini toplayabilmek şimdiki ve
gelecek nesillere üretebilmek için ya
Şimdiki derken işleri şu an size
paylaşabiliyor olmak için bu yolda
odaklandım konulardaki saat aşırı
kentleşme daha önce dediğim gibi iklim
değişimi Doğa tahribatı gibi konular
biliyorsunuz müşteriler son zamanlarda
çok önemli bir konum oy verdiniz ne
büyük kazançlar elde ederek
varlıklarını sürdüren şirketlerin
boşalttığı çeşitli kirli sularla e
sularla oluşmuş bir olay budur ona
çektiğim bir fotoğraf bazıları Ebru
zannetti bunu enteresandır Bu da gene
Kadıköy Sahillerinde Caddebostan
sahilinde çekilmiş bir gözümüzün
herhangi önünde olan bir Doğa kirliliği
olayı
hes'ler üzerine bir çalışma yaptık
sevgili eşim Sema gelmem burada bana Oo
çalışmada çok
yardımcı oldu ve
enerji ve siz bahanesiyle E çok
ulaştırılan son zamanlarda hes'lerin
Aslında
su haklarının özelleştirilmesi yolunda
ya atılmış bir adım olduğunu anladık
Çünkü biliyorsunuz diyorlar ki 20-30
seneye artık
bu Petrol üzerine değil su üzerine
olacak çeşitli savaşlar diye ve o orada
insanlarla konuştuk çeşitli bilgiler
edindik ve ben bunları
panolar yaptım orada gibi görüyorsunuz
el yazısıyla bazı bilgiler var o
bilgiler orada edindiğimiz ve
gözlediğimiz şeylerdir ondan sonra bu bu
yazıları yazarken kullandığım
kalemlerini sergide sergi salonunda
Müsait bir yere bıraktım 8-10 tane kalem
ve denk lütfen siz de katkıda bulunun ve
hayatımda şimdiye kadar herhalde
deneyimledim enine etkileşimli en
interaktif sergi oldu İnsanlar bir
şeyler söylemek istediler ve Burası
önemli
burası çokomelli Var ya işini bu
usal bhartiya bir adada ve burada
longran diye bir kasaba var bunu
Kasabanın ünlü de şu
dünyada Kuzey kutbuna en yakın ve en son
yerleşme
bu Burada gördüğünüz şu üçgen ucuz üçgen
olarak yukarı çıkan Fakat 6'da çok ve
daha geniş bir şekilde şekillenen ve
Eskiden bir Rusların Bir madeni olan
kömür madeni olan bir yer var ve bu
norveçliler burayı alıyor ve dünyadan
birçok
tohum toplayarak bu burada bunları Dep
oluyorlar bir tohum kasası sil volt
deniyor buna İngilizce ve Peki neden
burada bunu yapıyorlar Burası 2500
kişilik bir küçük bir kasabada biz altı
gün kaldık orada her daim karanlıktı bu
özel bir teknikle çektiğim için aydınlık
duruyor fotoğraf ve ve burada permafrost
denilen bir şey var perma kalıcı demek
biliyorsunuz ve frosta zaten donma ile
alakalı bir kelime
Bu Toprağın üst katmanları Hatta üstünde
altında olan bölümlerde kalıcı olarak
buz altında sene boyunca Fakat ne yazık
ki bu
burada Mesela görülen bir şey bu
yer üzerine çıkarılıyor bazı altyapı
çalışmaları Neden Çünkü bu permafrost
tabakası artık erimeye başlamış ve orada
konuştuğum bu tohum kasasına beni
sokmadılar maalesef
orada konuştuğumda bir yetkili bana dedi
ki siz de zaman coğrafyalarda küresel
ısınmanın etkilerini çok yavaş bir
şekilde görüyorsun Sen en olmadı
diyorsunuz ki bu kış biraz daha sıcak
geçti yani yeteri kadar yağ yakar ya
açılan çok kar yağıyordu Şimdi yağmıyor
ya da işte bu bu yaz arttı sıcaklıklar
falan gibi çeşitli bi gözlemlerle işin
vahametini anlamadan
bir şekilde gözler Siz de biz burada
gözümüzün önünde her gün bir şeyler
oluyor dedi Ve o yüzden de çok
endişeliyiz küresel ısınmadan
Evet bu da başka bir
pirada bu sefer grönland'a bakıyoruz
grönland'ın üzerinde orada bir Rehberden
öğrendiğimiz kadarıyla en kalın yerinde
3.2 kilometreye Varan kalınlıkta bir buz
tabakası var ve korkunç büyükten
bahsediyoruz uyku ve korkunç bir
kitleden bahsediyorum ve bazıları diyor
ki buz gibi değil zaman
bu buzun içine hapsolmuş
çeşitli hastalıklar var Dünya üzerinde
eradike edilen ya silinen ve buz
eridiğinde o hastalıkların tekrar
hortlaması söz konusu olabilecek diye
bir
öngörü var böyle tabi müthiş dramatik
coğrafya altında uçaktan çekilmiş
fotoğraflar Bu arada ben çok seviyorum
uçaktan çekim yapmayı drone kullanamadım
yerlerde Eve burada bir daha vermek
istiyorum size Geçen yaz belki
hatırlarsınız ya bu geçtiğimiz yazdığı
da bir önceki yazı yani 2022 yılında
Avrupa'da bazı kentlerde bu 40° ile bazı
Rekorlar kırıldı Yani daha önce hiç
kaydedilmeyen sıcaklıklar kaydedildi ve
o sıcak hava dalgasının tam bize doğru
Türkiye'ye doğru gelmesi söz konusu iken
birden gronland adasının olduğu yerlere
doğru kaydı ve bir gün grenland tabuhan
3.2 kilometre buz tabakası olan yerde
çok net hatırlıyorum rakamı 11 milyar
ton buz Eridi ve
veya korkunç bir şeyden bahsediyoruz
korkunç bir
pizza nasıl değil mi ya 20'den
bahsediyoruz ve bu tabi suları belli bir
derece yükseltmiş olmadı ki venedikte
Aqua Alper diye adlandırılan ve her sene
olan bir suların yükselmesi vardır bazı
Sokaklar suyla kaplandı falan ama çok
alıştıkları bir şey olduğu için
önlemleri almışlardır ve bir şey olmaz o
2020 yılında o Güven alttaki ve bu buz
erimesinden sonra
Venedik de hiç kaydedilmemiş yükseklikte
bir Aqua oluştu Yani şu beklediklerinden
çok daha fazla yükseldi ve
beklemedikleri bazı zararlar verdi
bunlarda buzdağları
bıçağı çok az kaldı bitiriyorum şimdi
biliyorsunuz organik tarım çok
kullanılan bir kelime ama tam olarak
organik bir şeyler yapmak
imkansıza yakın Çünkü çevre şartları da
çok önemli olduğu için yani sessiz çok
iyi bir şekilde tarım yapıyor
olabilirsiniz ama çevre arazide çevre bu
ya komşuların yaptığı tarımda herhangi
bir zehir kullanılıyorsa ya zehir derken
kimyasal
sizin iyi tarım yapıyor ya da organik
tarım yapıyor olmanız hiçbir şey ifade
etmiyor çünkü kontaminasyon oluyor yani
araziden
hastalık yapıyorsunuz bir şekilde ve bu
yüzden de daha mütevazı bir bu olarak
iyi tarım kullanılıyor bunun İngilizcesi
good agricultural Toprak tesis diye ve
biz de bir yaşındayım Hani bazı
şeylerden şikayet ediyoruz ve şikayet
etmekle bu işin bitmesi gerekiyor Yani
ben bazı hassasiyetleri mi burada
belirtin Peki ne yapıyoruz bu konuda
yani şikayet etmekle olmuyor ki bir
çözüm Önermek lazım Önermek içinde o
çözüm Acaba mümkün mü Onu araştırmak
lazım ve biz d8a ile bir araya geldik
böyle bir Çiftlik kurduk ya da Eko köyde
diyoruz ona ve burada Baya ciddi hiçbir
piers zehir sokmadan hiçbir
kimyasal sokmadan bu
burayı yürütmeye çalışıyor çok şifremiz
var çok zorlanıyoruz emin olun fakat
ürettiğimiz şeyden Çok eminiz çokta
keyifle tüketiyoruz şu an itibariyle
Sadece bize yetecek şekilde yapıyoruz
ileride bu büyükşehirden tam
Korktuğumuzda hayatımızda biraz kazanmak
için farklı bir ölçeğe çıkabiliriz
burada bir şey söylemek istiyorum
toprakla olan ilişki insanın insanı olan
ilişkisi gibi değil tam ya çok daha
direkt bir ilişki var ya siz ona ne
kadar iyi davranırsınız O da size o
kadar iyi davranıyor ama siz onay iyi
davranmaya eksik ederseniz o o size
küsmüyor gene yapıyor bir şeyler ya size
her zaman senin rızkını veriyor öyle
değil o yüzden toplu toprakla bir arada
olmak çok çok değerli gerçekten
elektriği güneş panelleri ile alıyoruz
şebekeye bağlı değiliz çünkü şebekeye
bağlı olmanız için paranın
değersizleşmesi nden önceki rakamla 300
bin lira falan yatırım yapmamız
bekleniyordu bizden öyle bir şey
istemedik Tabii ki onun yerine çok daha
ucuz Güneş panellerine yatırım yaptık bu
Sağdaki de sıramız Küçük Güzeldir çok
içtenlikle söylüyorum bunu küçük ölçekli
bu değiştirebilir hedefler belirlemek
bağımsızlık ve Krizlere dayanıklılık
sağlıyor kızlar da çok etkileniyorsunuz
Çünkü küçüksünüz zaten Kimin yazdığı
belli olmayan yapay zekaya teslim
olmadan emanet lerimizi savunmaya ve
savunanlara işbirliğine dayanışmaya
tevazu tasarruf ve kanaate devam 8
şeritli bir otoyol yerine orman yolunda
ilerlemeyi yeğenlerim bu yolda da
sevgili eşim de sonuna kadar
gitmeyi isterim bu kadar